hello and welcome everyone to today's
session
on modernizing texas's best retail chain
with anthos
my name is joe rodriguez platform
engineering manager for heb
responsible for hybrid cloud deployment
hi i'm justin turner i'm the senior
engineering manager responsible for
digital fulfillment at heb
today we'll talk a little bit about who
we are as a company and hopefully peel
back the onion and share with you
our road to platform modernization with
anthos and the effects that it's having
on helping us ship digital assets to heb
and to
our customers to be clear this is not an
exhaustive technical talk but rather
a behind the scenes look at some of the
thinking and decision-making that went
out
went into building out the platform and
our technical competency
therefore i will cover the work and
rationale that we put into building the
platform
and how we got here and my colleague
justin will cover the details of
engineering applications
on the platform for his digital
fulfillment team who are we
we are heb we are texas proud we believe
that no store does more for texas than
heb
we are the largest retail grocer in
texas and have the distinct pleasure
of serving over 9 million hungry texans
daily within our store footprint
we held from the great city of san
antonio but in actuality our humble
beginnings started in kerbal texas
in 1905. heb later moved its
headquarters in the 1940s to corpus
christi texas
but for the last 35 plus years we have
called san antonio home
here's an example of one of our flagship
stores in the houston area
and although each store is unique into
their own right
they are all set up to do the same they
are set up to efficiently
and effectively serve our customers
as you can imagine from a little bit of
math we are 115 years young
in that 115 years we've managed to
deploy
400 plus stores within our fleet now
those stores range from central south
east and now west texas
over 350 of them but now we also have
about 70 plus stores in northern mexico
according to dun hubby a data science
firm out of the uk
in 2019 they put out a study to
see who is the best retail grocery
company for the us
for 2020 they're happy to say that we
were voted
number one regardless of any accolade
you should know this as a company heb is
relentless
we are relentlessly dedicated to our
customers getting food into the homes of
hungry families
in a timely fashion especially during
this crazy time in history is our number
one
objective even so we do this while
trying to provide the best service
price customer experience whether in our
stores or online
it's who we are under platform
modernization
why modernize our platform simply put
it's about
serving texans it's what we do getting
food
into the hands and onto the tables of
our texans is what this is about
although it sounds simple every day this
task seems to get increasingly
more and more complex which is why we
know that if we're going to be serving
the lone star state
over the next 115 years this journey to
platform modernization and digital
transformation is and will be the key to
our future
and success now before modernizing
anything we had to do a bit of
introspection and realignment
in other words we had to get our heads
straight
did i mention we're 115 years old you
should we should
think that we're a little bit wise well
luckily we were wise enough to realize
that
if we're going to be solving today's
food problems with yesterday's tools and
technology
this would prove out to be a very tall
task
so what we did is we restructured and
aligned our engineering
operations and development teams for the
future and for success
the next thing we did was do a little
bit of planning we knew that this
digital transformation
uh does not happen overnight so we
started to plan for a minimum of
two a two to four year runway and when
it comes to
the platform itself we saw three phases
we call it crawl walk and run
but i will cover the next uh the the
first two phases and justin will
uh make mention of where we're headed in
the future at the end of the
presentation
one of the first things we did was
looked at the state of our devops
right and how we ship code hiv has this
concept of own brand
when you where we take something
good like ice cream and make it better
devops practices and tooling is no other
it is critical to
the path of the future tooling in
regards to tooling
this has to do with newer tools like
docker and kubernetes
and when it comes to delivering
applications we really had to take a
hard look at our cicd narrative
just by doing this we established our
early mission
which was a bold statement unto itself
and that is to empower developers and
accelerate heb's transformation from a
grocery
to a tech company but
like any good thing we've quickly found
out that this has some inverse effects
empowering developers and acceleration
of transformation
really has some inverse effects when it
comes to
delivering our applications much of what
my colleague
justin will cover is is exactly that
living in this new world
on this new stack and its effects on
application development
the next thing we did was address the
issue of change
change within the enterprises is very
hard change is hard in general but
for digital transformation it is even
harder i would care to say that no one
really knows just how hard something is
unless you have to go through it
yourself
when it comes to the enterprise i think
that the critical thing to remember is
that enterprises are much like
ships they are a little bit slower to
turn
which is distinctly different from a
startup approach right startups are like
tugboats speed boats or even smaller
vessels
they turn on a dime it takes an
incredible amount of retrofit work to
make ships turn on a dime like these
smaller vessels
from an operational perspective one
thing we had to do was a bit of
relearning or thinking or learning
differently
much of like you would from going from
an opera
object-oriented programming language
with something like java
to a functional programming language
with something like golem
the next thing we did was formulate a
team that could
really help us move the ball forward
what we did was we formulated a what we
called a gcp tiger team
this is a shout out to those key
individuals who helped on
who really helped early on to establish
the footprint
and and get us off to the races
what they did was really focus on
setting the groundwork right
building uh building that gap between
operations and developers
focusing on reshaping our culture
introducing those new tools
but in addition to that is really taking
a hard look at changing the computing
mindset of the organization
now you may ask what do you mean by that
well this is what we call our wizard of
oz moment
well considering that when we started
this it was 2017
and while the rest of the world was
moving towards 12 factor app and cloud
native
we were still living in the tightly
coupled world of servers
vms and mainframes think about it
servers vms
and mainframes servers memes and
maintenance oh my
you'll get the picture right what this
was about was rethinking our compute
mindset
decoupling applications from physical
servers or vms
and really taking a look at not treating
these resources as pets much like a cat
and really treating them more like
cattle i don't know about you but in
texas we're
way better hurting cattle than we are
pets
which led us to our container first
approach
we believe that this is the fastest
method of reinventing our platform and
delivering applications at scale
and into the future we did this by
engaging google
with gcp and gke one thing that we
didn't want to do is we didn't want to
reinvent the wheel so we focused on
becoming consumers
and establishing that that muscle memory
that it takes
to get good at delivering applications
what we focused on and what we tried to
get out of this was
three key things for our platform that
application decoupling that we talked
about
a faster engineering engineering life
cycle and a more systematic approach to
actually delivering the tools or rather
putting the continuous in continuous
integration and delivery
for our application deployment we sought
to have more uniform observability of
our applications
really focus on that operational agility
that most
uh high-performing uh institutions
uh look for these days and really taking
a policy driven approach or a a
securities code approach
to applications so wrapping up phase one
it took over about a year and a half
we managed to rewrite and migrate 16 16
to 18 production mainframe maps into gke
and so not to steal from any of what
justin is about to talk about but what
we
what we began to notice was a speed and
delivery
that operational agility that we were
looking for consistency
and overall developer happiness
so now we're feeling kind of comfortable
walking through with our heads in the
clouds
so the question now became how do we
bring this closer to home
how do we do this on prem for
applications that that need to sit
within our four walls
which led to a new mission right was to
accelerate our value creation for our
developers
and in addition shift the unit economics
of engineering
which really is just an intelligent way
of saying how
do we tackle certain applications to go
out first
now this is where the proper realignment
and introspection that i talked about
earlier
really really came into play this meant
that in order to be successful
operations developers engineers had to
be on the same place
such that there was frictionless
development world out world-class
operations
and automatic repeatability within our
systems inter
anthos why not why anthocell
you know there is a variety of solutions
out there currently
in in in in this space
but what we really wanted to do was
stick really close to open source
meaning we really were looking for a raw
kubernetes
experience right build continuing to
build on that technical competency that
we've just got through gke
and again leverage leverage that
existing support structure
that google provides us should we need
it
again what this is about is what why we
chose
uh antos as our platform for application
modernization was
that we're able to leverage existing
knowledge that exists within our data
centers in particular with vmware right
so antho sits on top of vmware and we
have a very large vmware footprint
we're able to make use of
our technical competencies to accelerate
the delivery of this
platform in addition to that tighter
grain control
deployment for compliance applications
should we need that the proximity to
data
we cannot put all of our data out into
the cloud
so having uh having these workloads run
very closely within our data centers
puts that data in close proximity to uh
to this
to these new systems again leverage
leveraging that existing
support and leveraging the experience
that we have with with google
in addition to that what we plan to do
in the future is is use this as a
burstable launch point into other clouds
is that one key feature that we haven't
made use of enthusiasm yet
so what this gave us were the essential
building blocks that we need to move
forward into the future
these buildings these building blocks
were you know composed of kubernetes
service mesh technology and and
serverless technology that we
quite haven't made use of yet but we
will here shortly
with that i'm happy to announce that we
have now officially launched our hybrid
cloud solution
at heb it took about nine months to sit
with google
and get this thing right but in february
of this year
we kicked off the project happy to say
that
now in july we are now uh in full beta
and we hope to go to full production
come august september time frame
we'll be sporting a new application
deployment approach with
git ops and some of the other tooling
like argo and what have you
in addition to that our initial
workloads will target only stateless
non-compliant applications
we wholeheartedly believe that we can
get a an adoption rate of five to
fifteen percent of the applications that
we need to re-engineer
and we can double that in 2021.
with that i'll now turn it over to my
colleague justin to talk about
his journey through modernizing digital
fulfillment
on our platform hey everybody
for the next part of this uh
presentation we're going to be going on
through a practical walkthrough
of how we took uh the path that joe
blazed with his teams and really
utilized that to modernize and transform
how we deliver work in digital
fulfillment
digital fulfillment are the engineering
teams and custom-built tools that power
our curbside and home delivery business
these are made up of web and mobile
applications as well as
delivery logistics smart routing
services that allow us to efficiently
deliver groceries to our customers
they are the tools that allow our make
ready departments to
on demand to prepare the items that are
a part of our customers orders
and they are the tools that allow our
partners to shop
manage orders and hand those orders off
efficiently
and correctly to our customers and
delivery drivers
so some of the reasons we wanted to
modernize digital fulfillment
were due to the fact that each of these
systems
grew up as a bespoke model at serving an
independent business need
and over time as our business grew and
changed the
the domains began to overlap more and
more which led to
duplicate functionality in each
application
as our business grew we knew we wanted
better tools to address the scaling that
came with that growth
and due to the nature of these systems
there's a tight symphony of events that
need to occur
to get our customers their groceries on
time and correctly
and any disruption can prevent us from
doing that
additionally the nature of the business
that we serve has changed as the
pandemic
goes on these tools allow our customers
to get groceries safely
and a disruption to that is uh something
we don't want
so uptime is of a mission critical
concern and we want a better tooling to
address it
we also have frequently changing needs
due to the nature of this
business each change just requested by
the business
simple as it may be may uh require
complex changes across the entire
all of these applications and the entire
ecosystem
so we knew we wanted to uh better serve
uh the need for change
so we decided that we needed a new
digital fulfillment
services ecosystem we asked ourselves
as an engineering group what we wanted
to get out of a modernization journey
and rebuilding these systems we knew we
wanted to deliver work faster
recover from incidents sooner we wanted
to be
more scalable and resilient to the
realities and complexities of operating
a complex system we wanted to empower
our engineers
to grow and learn more parts of the
stack than they had ever participated in
before
and learn a lot of the new cloud native
tools that are available to them
we also wanted single sources of truth
for every domain within digital
fulfillment
so we decided that a microservices
approach met these needs
that said we knew that the road to
microservices was fraught with risk that
we could create a distributed monolith
or a situation worse than what we
already had
so we came up with a simple set of
principles to help us
avoid these traps and be successful in
our journey
we wanted our services to be stateless
we wanted to reduce code complexity with
everything that we did
we wanted to encapsulate functionality
within services to reduce operational
complexity
as well as the chattiness between
services and we wanted loose coupling
between these services
so that we could fail gracefully and
keep most of the business up should a
failure occur
and we knew we wanted one database per
service
so to enforce the microservices
discipline
and ensure that we didn't create a
situation that was bad for ourselves
so the next step was to establish our
domain driven design
and we did this by following the event
storming process this allowed us to
define the events
triggers responses that make up the
digital fulfillment ecosystem
from there we take took the groupings of
these events
and formed our bounded context which
informed our domains
and ultimately led to the initial design
for our services
with this uh domain driven design we now
have what we needed
to get started we knew we didn't want to
show up with everything all at once with
a big bang approach so we picked the
overlap between last mile delivery
and curbside pickup domains to deliver
our first set of services
specifically in efficiently loading the
delivery vans
as they arrive to a curbside i'm happy
to say that we were successful in this
journey in august of last year
we delivered our first cloud native
services to production
it was a painful journey and we had a
lot of early learnings that informed the
rest of it
we learned you need to validate your
assumptions early and often about your
domain driven design
and how you've designed your services
and not be afraid to redraw boundaries
as you see fit
but you only learn about it by
validating those assumptions
we learned that we needed to invest time
in becoming familiar with cloud native
patterns we had a new tool set available
to us
but initially we only brought what we
already knew into the cloud so we had to
invest there
you also need to focus on the discipline
around you the principles
of your services as you get closer to
the finish line
the temptation is there to subvert your
principles to
uh meet the deadlines or what have you
and it might get you there sooner
but it creates a worse situation for
yourself down the road so discipline
around
your principles is key and important
and we also learned by doing a little
and getting those battle scars making
the mistakes early
we learned a lot and it made the rest of
our journey much smoother
with that experience
these changes allowed us to start
addressing our culture and digital
fulfillment and how we do work
we moved from two week sprints where we
would package up potentially shippable
product increments
and the risk of associated with two
weeks worth of work
and we're able to move to weekly kanban
iterations
where we were continuously delivering
value to production
we reformed ourselves from a giant
monolithic team
into several smaller squads that could
own their domains and services in the
end
and they did that by becoming full cycle
engineers and participating in more of
the stack than they had previously
we measured our success in this change
by
uh using the four key metrics that
allowed us to
identify areas of friction that
prevented us from becoming high
performing teams
to become full cycle engineers we had to
build competencies in parts of the stack
we had never really
operated in before we started with the
database and performing backups and
restores
as well as focusing on the efficiency of
our queries in a way we never had before
we also started building our own ci cd
pipelines
with cloud build and spinnaker and this
allowed us to do things like
introduce canary analysis to our
deployments
we then built a competency around
kubernetes itself and gke
and that allowed us to operate our
services
to end and fully own what we've built
we then uh learned a lot of different
tools in gcp that became available to us
one of which was bigquery it allowed us
to build
dashboards on the fly for our business
as well as uh understand uh our data in
a way we never had before
one of the other competencies that we
built was feature flagging
specifically utilizing a tool that we
built ourselves
for uh toggling features on and off in a
way that makes sense for heb
and we open sourced this tool with the
help of joe's team
we worked with him to introduce the role
of
sre to our teams we embedded these
partners on our squads
and they focused their efforts on
helping us define sli's slos
and refining our alerts until they were
actionable and meaningful
they also helped us to find good error
budget policies
and our stakeholders agreed to them
which allow us to change our behavior
should we exceed our error budget we
also refined our incident response
process
so that we can put our engineers on call
for what they build
and on healthy rotations so they can
really demonstrate that full
end to end ownership
the next thing that we did was build a
practice around chaos engineering we did
this by bringing in gremlin
who through the use of guided game days
helped us build a mindset around
introducing failure scientifically
to what we build this allows us to
validate all of our assumptions in our
designs
and really understand how our system is
going to perform when failures do occur
this has grown into red versus blue
exercises where we can practice incident
response
and is now growing even further into us
automating our chaos engineering
so we're at the point where our new
services are in production they're
rolling out
to stores and by the end of august our
full digital fulfillment ecosystem
should be live in every curbside
location
at heb
some of the key learnings at this stage
of the journey have been that change
safety is vital
as you start to move faster it increases
the risk that you can push an error to
production and so you need
a lot of automation around your testing
so you can move at that speed
as well as things like canary analysis
in your deployment pipeline to prevent
you from pushing things to production
that cause issues
you need to size your services for your
teams and what i mean by that is
as you remove complexity from your code
bases
you're introducing it into the operation
of your services
and not every team needs thousands of
microservices
so make sure that how you size your
services is something you can
successfully operate
we also learned that distributed systems
are really hard a lot of our issues here
at the end have been around
fine tuning our domain driven design and
redrawing those boundary lines and you
can't be afraid to fail
but this is where that validation of
your assumptions becomes key
as you need to refine as you go and not
have to redesign your system at the end
and build the muscle around distributed
systems ultimately
this doesn't end this is your new normal
we're doing this so we can better serve
our business but understanding that
there isn't a finish line to all of this
is
a key learning for us one of the most
important things we learned
is that focusing on the people is key to
a successful digital transformation and
that's because
the people that do the work are the ones
that bear the burden
of learning all of these new
technologies changing how they deliver
work the technical part of this is the
easiest part
providing a space for your people to
fail safely
to learn and investing in them is how
you
navigate this change successfully
so we're at the the next stage at the
end of august joe and i will be working
on our strategy to take what we've built
on gke
and transition it to gke on prim and
then
the move that to the edge in our stores
so that we have that ultimate level of
reliability our services can run right
next to our customers
and weather the storm when there's
unexpected events like a fiber cut
thank you for attending our talk if you
have any questions feel free to reach
out to joe or myself we appreciate you